a bad plan executed well we'll win we're
gonna be spoiled
this is spoiled you ready Nina yeah
alright it's day three I did my keynote
it's over I had a blast and now I got to
get my car get the Airbnb and then go
pick up Nina
[Music]
so Dallas has been amazing people have
been amazing my speech does that
airplane going over that's amazing my
speech was hopefully fire I felt good
doing it I practiced a lot doing it and
then I got up and I did it I get
non-stop adrenaline love from everybody
I deal with like I came here because of
my friend Jeremy best he asked me to
speak he asked me to close it with the
keynote like absolutely happy to do it
but once I'm here I do it for the people
you know like I want to I want to be
used I want to have an impact want to
reach people and I always try to make
people understand how important it is to
up their game like we're here I'm here
I'm away from Nina at least until now
I'm away from my son it's important I'm
away from you guys and wait from working
I'm here for three days like this has to
count and I need to bring my best and
you need to bring your best you need to
take the information that you learned
here today and like go do something stop
leaving with a notebook full of ideas
and then not take action 595 rule so in
five percent of your time planning and
95 percent doing do do coming to an
event like this doesn't count that's
planning thinking and strategizing isn't
work that's planning do you gotta
execute you got a doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo a bad plan
executed well we'll win a great plan not
executed we'll never win that's the end
of my starting to come through now I'm
starting to lose the ultra ultra high
energy level and just helping
entrepreneurs non-stop for the past
couple of days so I'm getting my car
here from the rental place I'm gonna go
get my Airbnb check-in before it gets
too late then pick up Nina from the
airport and it's our first time to
Dallas first time to Texas so we're
gonna spend a long weekend here in
exploring enjoying and take you guys
with us
all right this is my ride for the next
three days Texas Cadillac
[Music]
time to check out the Airbnb and it
would go look at this place these snazzy
his face is huge that big coach we got
here we got this guy what's up I know
you somewhere we got a bathroom nice
sink there's that guy again let's keep
walking
Wow Oh bedroom bedroom
that's a cool that's a cool door
overhead door alright that's a fancy
fancy TV
this place is giant it's just me and
Nina that's a huge screen okay clock
stairs stairs let's go up Wow look at
this place
you got fireplace catches everywhere oh
holy moly that's a giant kitchen how
they left us include look at this scoops
of corn chips and okay nice big fridge
oh yeah orange juice grapes
what are those peaches millions of
peaches just follow me millions of
peaches peaches for three all right
bathroom tiny little bathroom whoo
another bedroom a bedroom nice oh this
place keeps going it's just me and Nina
we shouldn't invite all you guys down
here believe nation meet up in Dallas
we're gonna be spoiled
this is spoiled I look at the pigs three
little pigs three blind pigs
what's the three pigs three little pigs
three three little pigs I'm a little pig
three blind pigs what's this all right
stairs that go up to the roof so this
place is pretty funky Nina just messaged
me she is boarding her flank that means
I've got what three hours in air for her
I set up my speech that I like to send
everyone back video DM when they
Instagram me so a whole bunch of you my
presentation Dallas decided to DM me on
Instagram so I got some work to do we're
spite of the people on the DMS but it's
a lot of fun I got a couple hours to
settle in maybe get some food
answered the m's and then pick up the
wifey because we've got three days to
get there okay got some great work done
it is quarter to ten not quite as much
as I'd like but the bare basics are done
the dm's are done the emails are done
most of the emails are done all of the
kind of
have to get stuff done Instagram post
done any of them era girl the major
stuff is done again not what I'd like
but maintenance mode ready to go it's
awesome it has these couple hours to to
get to work to catch up now it's Friday
night here it's weekend time got to pick
up the wife from the airport
woo show her this place I miss her
haven't seen you in a while
and fingers crossed you had a safe
enjoyable flight experience and is gonna
be insanely happy joyful and pleasant
when she gets off the airplane what do
you think yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're almost there
e 20 e 20 gimme Nina Nina let's go find
her
let's go find her let's go let's go
let's go Nina what we're here Nina I see
someone oh who is this person right
how was your flight my friend uh-huh we
missed you the whole belief nation
missed you
yeah you're looking very special you
know that you have a good flight you
excited to be here have some fun in
Dallas okay I mean I need them I need to
move or they're gonna suck even angry at
me okay off to the air baby you want to
say anything to believe nation oh okay
Wow
that's it you suck believe nation oh I
love you though remember I love you Nina
doesn't but I do okay give me a thumbs
up for me okay here we go
[Music]
[Music]
we made it Nina's a happy bunny she
thinks it's too hot why so hard this is
hot
the kids are on fire Wow you just came
from Canada you should ship you switched
anyway it's like almost midnight and
we're gonna get I need to get some food
haven't eaten so there's a place right
next to us called the green door public
house that we're gonna check out the
wife is a happy wife she has lots of
food in her stomach oh and now we get to
show her the inside of the Airbnb you
ready Nina yeah all right
this is the judgment call born ready
ha ha ha ha excuse me okay open up oh
this is the bedroom
my habit I need to change my shoes oh
they don't take off their shoes here no
[Music]
you happy now okay
you're the Dallas you get space okay
everything's bigger in Texas
what's a big TV screen there yeah it's
projector there that's the beer bottle
on the wall from Howard
yeah edges art
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
that's a lot of wine glasses for you to
drink from don't get drunk
[Music]
No now if your face was that small you
wouldn't really have a brain you can't
fit everything I'm just saying I know
I've seen you have a big brain you know
[Music]
this bathroom is
[Music]
you're gonna move the Dallas hashtag
Dallas love
[Music]
it's too dark to see anything oh you see
the city that's a nice view believe
nation can't see the garden bread
because it's too dark so that's far ok
listen hold on as far as they're
concerned there's zero garden beds
because we can't see we can't even see
you ok
there were no garden beds it's just a
bunch of black they have like a forest
back he looked back here they're growing
trees down there and then that's a
famous Dallas farmers market look at
that view that's a nice you that's
pretty cool for who for us the cave of
wheat then we've done it already we've
hosted it mean you whoa it's wobbly it's
legit wobbly I had a little bit of a
minor heart attack there that was a
little scary
felt like it was a roller coaster right
I was a kitten look ok let's go in here
Nina they're not talking to you mister
hello let's not have the cats come
inside our place ok this is it they
might they might be vampire cats vampire
kittens they turn you into a vampire to
bite you is that the plan it is
something romantic I just found you you
just came here alright well
what do you have to say enjoy your
weekend it's a long weekend Fred don't
think you guys for watching if you want
to watch my Dallas keynote speech the
link is right there next to me continue
to believe and we'll see you there
how many of you guys have no idea who I
am nice that's the best I love it